[Music]
early on in ursula k le guins tahana the
fourth earth sea novel
the great mage odeon the teacher of ged
who at that time is arc mage
and also the warder and teacher of tenar
will die
and tenar is going to be there and what
happens
is very important for setting the stage
and also displaying what's going on with
some of the key themes but there's also
something very important there's a
relationship between tenar
and ogian that that developed over time
he is her adoptive father as she's going
to say as she's telling
pharaoh the
the very young
terribly abused girl who almost died who
she has taken in that
uh
tenner is is her mother in the same way
that ogen was
her father
so this is you know in some ways
bringing a
climax early on in the story the death
of ogion but it's also a in some
respects
we get to see something of his life
in that and as it's going to turn out
his house will be a
major setting throughout
the entire novel they spend quite a bit
of time there after his death
and then they returned to it later on
uh
ten arged and theroux and so there's
there's a lot going on here there's also
a back story so in the tombs of otto on
the second novel it ends with
ged and and arhar tenor
who's at that time
you know a young woman
leaving ottowan the place where she grew
up the only place that she knows in the
kargash lands
and ged says i'm going to take you to
havnor we've restored the ring of ereth
akba they're going to see you as a
princess and she's like i don't really
like that idea this is not really for me
and then he says well you're not going
to stay there forever
i will take you to gant and i will take
you to my former master ogion who i
probably would have done better staying
with and you can stay with him and then
decide what you're going to do with your
your life so tenor does stay with ogian
and she studies with him for quite some
time we'll look at some of the passages
in which she's talking about that and
then she decides that she wants to to
leave and take up a different life she
becomes gohan
and
instead of being the you know kargish
woman
she becomes a gauntish woman she marries
has children
manages a household and a farm
one of her daughters marries and another
another farmer her son goes off to sea
and her husband will eventually die of a
stroke at the farm and she you know
makes a lot of friends and and talks to
a lot of people and makes connections
and retains a connection with ojin who's
still on gaunt of course he's never
going anywhere else and then when she
assumes the
responsibility for this this horribly
abused and nearly killed child whose
face has been eaten away by
fire on one half of it actually one of
her hands as well
she's going to take there with her
and she takes her to
ogeon in part because they need to go
there anyway this is at the beginning of
chapter 2. it was more than a year later
in the hot and spacious days after the
long dance a messenger came down the
road from the north to middle valley
asking for the widow gohan
people in the village put him on the
path he came to oak farm late in the
afternoon he looked at gohan and at the
sheep in the fold beyond her and said
fine lambs the mage of ray albie sends
for you
he sent you inquiring uh disbelieving
and and amused oh joon when he wanted
her had quicker and finer messages and
eagle calling or only his voice saying
her name quietly will you come the man
nodded
he's sick
and so
she goes on her way that very night
sets things up and takes uh uh
thera with her and they they make it to
uh ojin and she tells her we're going to
see an old man uh called ogian he's a
wise man and a wizard do you know what a
wizard is there and if the child had a
name she did not know it or would not
say it gohan called her thero she shook
her head
well neither do i said the woman but i
know what they can do when i was young
older than you but young ogian was my
father the way i'm your mother now he
looked after me and tried to teach me
what i needed to know
he stayed with me when he'd rather have
been wandering by himself he liked to
walk along these roads like we're doing
now and in the forest in the wild places
he went everywhere on the mountain
looking at things listening he always
listened so they called him the silent
but he used to talk to me he told me
stories not only the great stories
everyone learns the heroes and the kings
and the things that happened long ago
and far away but stories only he knew
and she says i'll tell you one of those
stories
now and she tells them
she tells her a very important story for
understanding the relationship between
dragons and human beings that has to do
with with ogen
when they get there they find ogen is
actually in a very bad way he's not just
sick
he is in fact
dying and
here we go
what we find
is
she she
goes and sat and sat down beside ogean's
pellet cross-legged on the floor no one
looking after you i sent them off he
whispered his face was dark and hard as
ever but his hair was thin and white
and the dim lamp made no spark of light
in his eyes you could have died alone
she said fierce
help me do that
the old man said
not yet she pleaded stooping laying her
forehead on his hand not tonight he
agreed
tomorrow
and he says you know if only ged would
come get is his uh pupil the the you
know person who uh tennar escaped from
atu on with and they discuss whether
he's lost or not
so tener is actually there to help ogen
not come back to life not to heal but to
have
the death that he wants to have outside
he doesn't want to die
indoors
and
a little bit later
um
we we find that he says
um
here we go help me get up no no
yes he said outside i can't die indoors
where would you go anywhere but if i
could the forest path he said the beach
above the meadow
when she saw he was able to get up and
determined to get outdoors she helped
them together they got to the door where
he stooped and looked about the one room
of his house
in the dark corner of the doorway his
tall staff leaned against the wall
shining a little
tenor reached out to give it to him but
he shook his hands no not that come on
he said it last
when the bright wind from the west blew
on his face and he looked out at the
high horizon he said that is good
and they walk and then they they come
they sank down between the roots of the
beech tree is back against its trunk for
a long time he could neither move or
speak in his heart pounding and
faltering shook his body
he nodded finally and whispered all
right
and then
she sends thero off to get a rug because
she won't you know tenar needs something
for a long time he did not speak but sat
back against the tree trunk his eyes
closed watching his face tenor saw it
change slowly as the light changed in
the west
he opened his eyes and gazed through a
gap in the thickets of the western sky
he seemed to watch something some actor
deed in that far clear golden space of
light he whispered at once hesitant as
if unsure
the dragon
and
there is indeed a dragon on the way as
we're going to find out
he gripped her hand and shut his eyes
and began once more the struggle to
breathe until there was no more breath
he lay then like one of the roots of the
tree while the stars came out and shone
through the leaves and branches of the
forest
tenor set with the dead man in the dusk
and dark
a lantern gleamed like a firefly across
the meadow
that night his neighbors sat with ogin
and he did not send them away so this is
how he dies outside
with somebody tenar
before that something else happens
he teaches her something or tells her
something about her ward
pharaoh
and
here we go
when little theroux woke he spoke to her
in the dry kind way ten i remember the
child went out to play in the sun and he
said to tenor what is the name you call
her
he knew the true language of the making
but he'd never learned any kargish at
all theroux means burning the flaming of
fire tenar said ah
that one that one they will fear her
they fear her now tenor said bitterly
the mage shook his head
teach her tenor teach her all not rock
they are afraid why did i let you go why
did you go to bring her here
too late
and she says be still
he struggled with words and breath and
could find neither he shook his head and
gas teach her and lay still so what we
what we see here is ogion is taking the
last bits of his energy and transmuting
them into language trying to convey a
meaning an imperative to tenor
she'll meditate on this what should i
actually teach her what what can i teach
her what is there to teach what does she
need to learn
there's one other thing that that
ojn is going to say as he's dying his
final words which i skipped over in
reading that passage but now we need to
think about it
over he whispered with exaltation all
changed changed tenor wait wait here for
those are his final words so there's two
components there everything is changed
he's not saying this in a gloomy way
everything has changed it's all going
downhill and notice this is at the same
time that all the events in the previous
novel are taking place the magic has
been going out of the world and get is
getting lebanon are the ones who will
write that that problem
instead it's exaltation things are
changing something new
is coming about
and there's going to be a lot of
meditation and discussion
meditation upon discussion of what could
that possibly
mean throughout the rest of the novel
and then
wait wait for what well as we'll find
out in uh the next chapters
wait for the dragon to come the oldest
dragon of all khaleesin bearing ged the
ark made drained of all of his power
upon his back that's what
what ogion was referencing and saying
the dragon so
things are about to change
radically and ogeen will not be there to
see them but he dies in his his place
then as is always the case what do you
do with the dead after they
have died
and
we find that moss the village witch
attends to what is called the homing of
the dead often to the burial
we have this this nice description
it was anti-moss who had come across the
metal with the lantern with tenor and
the others she'd watch the night by
ojin's body she set a wax candle on a
glass shade there in the forest and
burned sweet oils in a dish of clay
she'd said the words that should be said
and done what should be done when it
came to touching the body to prepare it
for burial she had looked at one once
ten are as if for permission and then
gone on with her offices
then we see these two wizards coming on
the scene there there are other wizards
on gaunt
when the wizard came down from the
mansion house a tall young man with a
silvery staff of pine wood and the other
one came up from gaunt poor to stout
middle-aged man with a short used staff
auntie moss did not look at them but
ducked and bowed and drew back gathering
up her charms and witcheries when she'd
laid out the corpses it ought should lie
to be buried on the left side with the
knees bent she'd put in the upturned
left hand a tiny charm bundle something
wrapped in soft goat skin and tied with
colored cord the wizard of rialby
flicked it away with this tip of his
staff
is the grave doug asked the wizard of
god port yes said the wizard of ray
albeit is dug in the graveyard of my
lord's house and he pointed towards the
mansion house i see said gone port i
thought our mage would be buried in all
honor in the city he saved from the
earthquake my lord desires the honor
said ray alby but it would seem gone
port began and stopped not liking to
argue but not
ready to give in to the young man's easy
claim he must be buried nameless i
walked all night became too late a great
loss made greater then tenor says
several things
his name is actually his name was i hall
and his wish was to lie here where he
lies now
so this is viewed as a kind of
impertinence by both of these wizards
both men looked at her the young man
seeing a middle-aged village woman
simply turned away the man from ganport
stared a moment and said who are you
i am called flint's widow goha she said
who i am is your business to know i
think but not mine to say and then we
have a prefiguring of what's going to
happen later the wizard of rialby found
her worthy of brief stare take care
woman how you speak to men of power
wait wait said gone port trying to calm
ray alby's indignation and still gazing
at tenor you were you were his ward once
and friend tenor said then she turned
his head
away her head and stood silent she had
heard the anger in her voice as she said
that word friend she looked down at her
friend a corpse ready for the ground
lost and still they stood over him alive
and full of power offering no friendship
only contempt
rivalry
anger
and then
auntie moss actually intervenes kind of
courageously she says yes she was nobody
else but her he sent for her he sent
young towns in the sheep dealer to tell
her come clear around the mountain and
he waited his dying till she did come as
one was with him and then he died and he
died where he'd be buried here
and then
tenar says
he told me his name
must i repeat it to you to her
consternation she saw from their
expressions they had in fact not heard
the name ogian's true name they had not
paid attention to her
oh she said this is a bad time a time
when even such a name can go unheard is
listening that power listen then his
name was i hall his name and death is i
hall in all the songs he will be known
as eye hall of gaunt if there are songs
to be made anymore and then she tells
them
will you see to it his grave is dug here
where he desired it first the younger or
the older man than the younger nodded so
they they accede to her
wishes because they are ogen's wishes
right and tener is the one who who knows
she is the one who is connected with him
these others have a professional
relationship you could say and want to
run things
but it's actually tenor who is the one
who
can do that because she she knows oj and
loved ojin they were they were friends
and so we see ogian's life come to an
end
it's not the end of his legacy of course
ged
and ten are and in a certain respect
theroux
who tenor has been told to educate in
some way
are
in some respect ogen's adopted children
and grandchildren and they live
in his house kind of unexpectedly for a
while and then
move on coming back to it towards the
end
you